hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to missed fortune a game
where you are lost on an alien ship and
apparently there's a deadly mist seeping
through the doors it's gonna kill you at
any moment and apparently I'm gonna die
because everyone else here is dead
except for me and maybe this which
contains some horrible gases but I'm not
entirely sure hello oh the [ __ ] was that
who is talking to me
oh you're jiggly Lou physics-based I
like it
why am I here hello hello what do I just
got to walk into the mist and then die
horribly ow ow ow okay then that's not
right so maybe I gotta use this to suck
wool I do gotta use that to suck yeah oh
[ __ ]
ah okay how do I direct it ah wha Oh ah
okay all right then well that didn't
work
apparently I'm part of a cleanup crew
that all died ha ha ha ha we're dead
oh no here - I'm lon help - ok touch to
fix the power supply well if it was that
easy why didn't you do it your dick you
just had to die laying your head down by
the seeping mist dang open alrighty then
I did it I think oh boy ok
are you the last remember oh you'll get
your [ __ ] Hey
whoa whoa our buddy I don't want anybody
I don't want anybody I don't want any
get sucked it sucked
trap seriously yeah yeah a trap
seriously it's called my sucking trap
you get sucked and then you die oh no
fat this is not a sucking trap it was a
lie Obon much my persistence oh okay my
desperation doesn't match your
persistence I don't know maybe you're
trying to kill me oh oh [ __ ] oh god
gonna die
what a saint good oh boy oh boy I'm dead
I'm dead under [ __ ] well [ __ ] Oh now the
doors open oh great I really appreciate
the voice acting shelter uh uh no fat
how about you get what it's agile I
really mean that much for him yeah yes
no okay
well that didn't answer a lot of
questions
no I won't why are your rhyme they said
of work for anyone
uh-huh okay but I am persistent around
forever yes you're on the chaff oh man
you did my so soon reliable are they
you don't know that no y'all I gotta get
to the suckage Oh God that's not the
site nope that's no good okay well I am
at a loss
there's gotta be a way to I can't jump
there's no e to jump but I can crawl oh
man yes yes well this year's one kind of
life yeah all right uh carbon life is
awesome we get sex and movie sticks and
I don't know what you said but I don't
like it and also such life forms can you
destroy it for full and horse farmed I
don't I don't know I haven't destroyed
all that anymore once lo use artificial
food felt so tasty to them yep
calm down watch it your life this is not
why I do what I died
Sookie deserve because you seem to want
to kill me down
your life yes this is not why I do
uh-huh yeah tell me more about how you
won't eat near lash the prey no swim
much what for surviving and seeing my
family welcome to my world
okay okay oh that was the end
what okay
oh I'll create it in 48 hours oh okay
that was pretty good it wasn't quite as
scary as it could have been uh it was
this kind of like this lumbering thing
coming after you and taunting you but
either way the voice acting was very
good made it very ethereal in like this
this very intelligent mist form don't
know why it existed and I wanted to know
more about it but this is why like these
indie horror games that you find on
gamejolt they're like a little window
into what could be they're a little
snippet of potential and you see
something good and you're like oh this
is cool and then you remember it's made
by a small team and it's made in such a
short amount of time and you're like oh
I've one more and this is made for an
asylum jam and it's like there could be
more out of this and I want to see more
that's what I get out of these indie
horror games I want to see more you see
the talent and you see what could be
with these interesting very basic ideas
and when you see potential like it's
there and this is there so either way
let me know what you think down the
comments below and thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye